a couple of weeks ago we did a piece
about net neutrality and there was a
moment in it where we pointed out that
Tom wheeler the chair of the FCC which
is tasked with regulating cable
companies was previously a lobbyist for
the cable industry something of a
conflict of interest that we summarized
thusly that is the equivalent of needing
a babysitter and hiring a dingo church
it's a little offensive to Australia's
favorite baby eating animal but needs
much for the job and look you're
probably wondering why I'm playing it
again now well on Friday the FCC held an
open meeting and this happened I'm just
wondering if you watch the John Oliver
segment about net neutrality and what
you thought oh
bothers no it's good so what did he
think I think that it represents the
high level of interest that exists in
the topic in the country and that's good
I can't know I mean I I would like to
State for the record that I'm not a
dingo
first-first Wow and second we never said
you were a dingo we said you were like a
dingo but now you're denying it so
strenuously I'm honestly starting to
wonder whether you are actually a dingo
after all he even tried to throw us off
the scent by pretending not to know what
a dingo even is I had to go look it up
it's a feral wild animal restroom here's
the thing that's exactly the kind of
thing a dingo would say if he didn't
want anyone to know he was a dingo I
mean just look at a split screen right
now go like this it's uncanny think
about it if you if you shave the one on
the Left would it not look a little like
the guy on the right because now I have
lots more questions wheeler such as have
you at any time ever consumed a swamp
wallaby for its nutrients you probably
have your dingo what's your
answer to that I'm not a dingo you you
keep saying that but now the burden of
proof is on you unless you can produce
an official document verified by license
you want
certify that you are in fact got a 100%
talking dingo I don't think you can
complain if Americans refuse to leave
you alone in rooms with their babies
because you'd eat them you would eat up